en tant que canicule on nous dit souvent
de bien s'hydrater mais c'est quoi une
bonne hydratation et comment éviter la
déshydratation
[Musique]
sur un campus déserté dans les premières
chaleurs de l'été un étudiant s'entraîne
puis athlète et doctorant Antoine joli
coeur des roches s'intéresse aux
mécanisme de l'hydratation
déshydraté ta performance est déjà
affectée puisqu'on leur observé dans nos
études puis dans ce qu'on fait au
laboratoire c'est que tu as quand même
une certaine marge de manœuvre qui
permet de quand même bien performer donc
c'est pas comme dette qui commence à
être un petit peu déshydraté ta
performance est complètement affectée
pour la plupart d'entre nous il est
plutôt facile de maintenir une bonne
hydratation au quotidien mais cela
devient beaucoup plus ardu dans tes
contextes extrêmes moi je m'intéresse à
comprendre l'impact de l'hydratation et
la thermorégulation donc la contrôle la
température corporelle sur la
performance humaine en laboratoire
Eric Goulet et son équipe note une série
d'indicateurs
en fait la soif est réglée finement par
l'organisme c'est que l'organisme en
fait veut réguler contrôler la quantité
de sodium si vous voulez grosso modo
simplement expliquer de la quantité du
sel qu'on trouve
dans les liquides corporelles si on fait
l'exercice à l'extérieur on part de
l'autre à travers la sudation pour se
refroidir on va perdre un petit peu de
sodium beaucoup d'eau les concentrations
vont augmenter et c'est ce signal là qui
donne la soif à ce moment-là on va avoir
un sentiment bouche sèche on va ingérer
du liquide en ingérant l'équipe ça va
augmenter la quantité d'eau et diluer la
quantité de sodium et donc rétablir
l'équilibre
notre organisme est constitué à 60%
d'eau l'équilibre hydrique c'est la
quantité de liquide que le corps humain
doit maintenir pour s'assurer une
hydratation adéquate
[Musique]
on part environ 2 litres d'eau par jour
alors faut les récupérer ouais il faut
boire mais tous les liquides vont
ramener de l'eau mais aussi tous les
fruits les légumes si on est dans une
alimentation saine variée équilibrée
comme le recommande le Guide alimentaire
canadien la moitié de notre poste ça
devrait détruire des légumes mais des
fruits des légumes c'est 85 à 90% de
l'eau alors si on a ce genre
d'alimentation là par la suite boire
quelques verres d'eau dans la journée ça
va aller
difficile d'établir une recommandation
générale quant à la quantité de liquide
à boire quotidiennement plusieurs
facteurs vont influencer l'alimentation
le niveau d'activité physique et l'âge
par exemple et pour ce qui est de l'idée
largement véhiculé du 8 verres d'eau par
jour elle ne sait pas la route un
chercheur c'est intéressant à savoir
d'où ça venait et on l'a jamais trouvé
donc ça c'est quelqu'un qui
est assez perpétuer sans nécessairement
vérifié scientifiquement parlant je
dirais en général je pense la moyenne la
population pas de gros problèmes de
déshydratation et le truc pour savoir si
on est bien hydraté c'est le volume et
la couleur de l'urine alors tôt le matin
c'est plus concentré ça va être jaune
plus foncé le reste de la journée ça
devrait être une urine claire et
abondante la couleur qu'on dit c'est
comme la limonade
[Musique]
ce qui signifie c'est modérément
déshydrater
une couleur sombre foncée presque brune
indique une déshydratation alors qu'une
absence de couleur indique une
sur-hydratation et possible de trop
boire des trous hydraté ça arrive quand
même assez souvent dans des gros
marathons des grosses épreuves que les
gens vont juste trop boire surtout de
l'eau sans les électrolytes ce qui fait
ta concentration de sodium dans ton
corps ton métro dilué en fait je pense
de suivre s’asseoir c'est le meilleur
indicatif ici ça fonctionne bien pour
quelqu'un qui fait du sport de haut
niveau ça va bien fonctionner vraiment
pour quelqu'un qui qui va seulement
aller courir la fin de semaine un petit
peu
[Musique]
les équipes de voirie travaillent avec
du bitume atteignant 150 degrés et plus
un jour Sylvain Lamarche a mesuré la
température ambiante et puis au moment
de terminer je suis sorti puis j'ai
regardé le thermomètre sur le
thermomètre faisait après jusqu'à 50
degrés Celsius la température extérieure
a été environ 35 degrés je pense c'est
ça le problème avec l'hydratation c'est
qu'on y pense pas quand on travaille
là-dessus tant qu'on n'a pas le choix
tant qu'on le ressent à fond on est
concentré à faire un travail puis c'est
là que ça peut devenir dangereux il
existe aussi un phénomène appelé coup de
chaleur comme l'explique le docteur
David Kaiser de la Direction de la santé
publique de Montréal tout le monde a
peur un peu l'image en quand il fait
chaud d'un coup de chaleur alors on est
dehors on fait de l'exercice puis tout
d'un coup ça vaut bien on peut sentir
des nausées des maux de tête et puis ça
peut être une urgence médicale ça c'est
quand la température du corps augmente
très rapidement c'est
la réponse tirant de refroidir la
personne quand on parle de canicule ce
qu'il faut faire c'est s'exposer
minimalement à la chaleur ou si on le
fait s'accorder davantage de pause à
l'ombre c'est surtout de pas rester à
côté du travail donc c'est éloigner un
peu on va prendre une petite pause on va
aller à l'ombre on va boire de l'eau
beaucoup d'eau
les signaux de la soif sont parfois plus
difficiles à percevoir chez certains
groupes d'individus comme les personnes
âgées ou les personnes qui ont des
problèmes de santé il faut donc être
particulièrement vigilant lors des
périodes de grande chaleur
car il fait chaud pendant plusieurs
heures voire plusieurs jours il y a une
déshydratation alors ça c'est une chose
ou ce que progressivement on part de
l'eau peut-être un peu sans s'en rendre
compte ou nos mécanismes sont pas à
point et puis après ça c'est sûr que il
y a une
augmentation
progressive tranquille de la température
du corps et puis ces deux choses là
ensemble on met de la pression du stress
sur les systèmes ça soit sur les poumons
le cœur les reins et c'est pour ça qu'on
voit après quelques jours de canicule
des effets importants sur la santé dont
des décès en lien avec la chaleur
mais dans un contexte d'activité
d'intensité moyenne de chaleur moyenne
et pour les personnes relativement en
santé le meilleur conseil est de se fier
aux signaux de notre corps moi je vous
dirais si vous sentez que vous êtes plus
de bonne humeur le fun votre journée de
plein air là-dessus d'être dehors puis
il fait beau puis essayer de voir
avez-vous assez buts puis pensez au plus
petit aussi parce qu'elles ont-ils
sentent pas pile voient pas venir
autrement pour aller passer la journée
avec les enfants à vélo une ou deux
bouteilles d'eau une bouteille de jus un
fruit
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
[Musique]